Hi! My name is Markiplier and I'm here with my mom, (MAMAAAA)
also known as Momiplier. How you doing?
Mom: Hi everybody.
*Epic show song for Momiplier*
Mark:  Yeah, and toda-... Mom: This is Bell!
Mark:Yeah it's Bell.
*Epic show song for Bell* *dogiplier*
Mark: Today we're going to be doing the How Well Do You Know Your Child...
Game.(no its not)
Something like that. ( what do you mean)
There is an official name for it. Ehhhh, something like.. "parent tag"? (i guess)
I don't know what it is. This is years old at this point but...
I figured it was a good..time for the audience to know, if you know me very well.
Mark: Uh- I'll.. I'll ask, I guess. I'll do all the work.
Mom: Okay.
Mark:Who are my enemies?(yeah who is his enemy)
Wait...
Mom: Peedeepaih! (Pewdiepie)
Mark: I didn't get to write my thing.. ( proceed to laugh together as a family)
*Momiplier laughs*
Mom: I'm sorry. ( still giggling )
Mark: And- hang on I'll give you a.. I'll give you a do over.
Mom: Say it again. What's your.. que-question?
Mark: Who are my enemies?
*PATPATPAT*
Mom: Jacksepticeye
*both giggle*
Mom: No? *laughing*
Because you guys kinda neck-and-neck
*laughs again*
Mark: I don't know what kind of ruthless world do you think YouTube is. *laughs*
Mom: It's a vicious competition to each other.(that makes sense)
Mark: O h
Mom: They trying to stab each other's back, right? (not all the times)
Mark: Well, I'll... I'll tell...
I'll tell Jack that when I see him later today.
*Both laugh*
My answer was "da haterz". (haters gonna hate)
Mom: What haters?!?
Who hate'chyu?! *Mark laughs* How dare *echo slam* they hate Markiflier?!
Mark: Alright. What is my favorite music? Now think about it...
Mom: *Eerie music plays* Favorite music... favorite music
ppfftt favorite music? *Who wants to be a Millionaire guess face*
What did you make the album? What's the title of the song? What is it...
Mark: - I made an album?(naniiiiiiiiiii)
Mom: Yeah.. year ago.
Something you si- st- s--
..sing with a guitar. What is the name of that?
Mark: - Oh, I did a cover. (that is okay)
Mom: Cover. What was the title?
Mark: - I did it was.. uhm.. I ... Eh ooh aeh wel--
All that's coming to mind is "oh say can you see" but that's not it.
- Nooo.. There was cover song. What was it?
I'm.. trying to.. remember!
- Oh gosh!
Wait, okay. It's.. it's um.. Ed Sheeran's uh- bal- epic ballad "Oh say, can you see". That was it.
That's it. Yeah, your favorite.
- Yeah.. But that's wrong...
... Fu'hnk?
- Funk
What is that? Funk? They're for the...
- Funk is...
Try... say something.
*Momiplier sniff*
[Funk imitation fail from Mark]
Uh-(wow)
You might la-like it- it's not for you.
My favorite band is "Here Come The Mummies". It is an awesome, awesome band. I love'em.
Okay, now we're getting into the serious questions
What is my biggest complaint about this family?
This family? Which family?
- Our... Our family.
Complaint?
- Yeah, what's my biggest complaint? Uh ooh...
Oh, wait. I know. Hang on.
- What you talking about? *puts on glasses*
Well, I didn't I- I haven't written the answer yet.
- I know one.
I don't... haven't written the answer yet. Hang on.
Okay, what is it?
HOW DARE YOU... COMPLAIN ABOUT THIS FAMILY...
(d i s s a p o i n t m e n t)
*Mark lets out a hearty laugh*(momipleir sad about mark)
How dare you...
I think I kind of um... I know what you just talking about.
( ( S L A M ) )
As an asian parent, you know what we like to do?
Force-feeding children.
(confused-iplier activated)
First thing I ask is "Are you hungry?"
Then I say "Wait a minute! I cook for you!" Is that the one?
That's not a complaint. No, my complaint was: "I don't get to see you all enough".
*laughs*
Ooh...
Haha-hahahaha!.. But I love the clip of... *slam*
"How dare you complain". *yell-laughs*
That's not complain! That is a nice thing!
This- I complain! I've been away for four years and I don't get to see you all enough!
- Oh yeah. Okay okay okay...
I thought oh... how dare you *laughs*
- Wow! Oh my goodness.
It better be nice...
- Bueet wuet... I have the... My last answer was lovely!
If I could buy you a- this is a little reverse-- If I could buy you..
Anything in the... Here, actually, I'll just give you this. Here.
Write down write down your answer. I'll take Bubble. Er- Bell. That's Bell.
Yes it's Bell.
- I'll take Bell oooerrrrnnnnnggghhhh
Now you write down your answer to this question.
- Okay.
Don't show me. If I could buy you...
anything in the world, what would it be?
- That's a tough question, dear...
I know right? Don't let me see it. But now I'm gonna answer.
- Anything?
If I could buy you anything in the world what would it be?
Bell... You all ready for shopping? Spree?
Your brother's going to buy us anything in the world.
I don't accept you as my sister... *Marks death stare*
*Momiplier laughs heartily*
* d e a t h  g l a r e *
Bell, get ready for shopping. Your brother is gonna buy us..
- You sure are writing a lot down!
Oh com'h on! You said "anything"!
- Any ONE thing.
Oh any one thing?
- Yeah!
Have to be  any one thing?
- How am I gonna guess a bajillion things?
( d i s s a p o i n t e d )
*chuckle*
Don't give me that disappointed sound. This isn't reality. I'm not actually gonna buy you these things.
Ohk'mon! I take it literally your question here.
- Wai- what!?
There you go! This is what I want!
- Don't show me I haven't answered yet!
Oh okay?
- I got a guess it. Alright is it...
Okay, you wrote down multiple things. A new car, a new house... Uhhh uhhh...
Uhhh uh... An island in the Bahamas
Uh... paid vacation uhhh... a... uuhh... uh...
A fleet of servants to clean and cook for you?
Did I get it?
- Wroooonnnng!
Okay wow...
-Apparently, you don't know me.
Apparently, I don't. Wh- what was it?
Ta-daaahhh!
- What is that, a seal?
Seaalll... *Momiplier giggles*
Say it again- Bell! Who's it look like?
- Looks like se- Bell as a mermaid...
Yeah.. Bell..
- Wh- what did...
Bell! Another Bell!
Boy Bell.
*laughs*
It'd be cute.
I want me.. I want them to have a nice puppy.
There's too many dogs in the world. You don't need to breed'em.
Oh.. it's so cute, it's okay...
Besides they don't make it-- that many puppies. If they're lucky- if I'm lucky they might have...
( ( O N E ! ) )
Alright, well, you got me good on that one. Okay, so that's a point minus for me.
Perfect. Very nice drawing by the way.
- Mmm??
Nice drawing.
- I've been practicing.
Alright, what is...
... my...
.. .fff-favorite...
... TV show?
Oh I know...
- Wait hang on...
I know.
- Alright go for it.
Oh- Doctorrrr...
... House? Doctor No? Either one.
Whuhoohooo--aath?
- What's the line!!
What's the line?
- Yeah, whose the line.
Whose the line is it anyway?
- Yeah.
Yeah yeah! You got it!
I don't know what Doctor No-House came into that but...
You used to... you used to... into the Doctorrr No.
- Yeah yeah but... good thing you settled...
Yeah good thing you settled on "Whose Line Is It Anyway" 'cuz that is.. that is my favorite show.
Yeah yeah.. yeah.
- Whoa you got one. Wow!
You don't think I pay attention on my sons?
What they doing?
You gotta be..
- You watch everything.
I . w a t c h . e v e r y t h i n g .
Okay. This one will probably be an easy one. What accomplishment am I most proud of?
Raising money for charity.
( ( p a n i c k - i p l i e r ) )
Did you write down already?
Am I too fast?
-No- I'm- is that your--
Yeah?
"My Youtube?"
( ( y i k i e s  g a n g ) )
W-Which allowed me to raise money for charity, so
-Yeah, how would you raise money if you didn't have your Youtube channel?
YEAHHHAHAH!
Nobody gonna donate a dollar for you, if you didn't have a you- channel. Right?
-Yeah
(  (  S  L  A  M  )  )
We'll count that as a point.
- Yeah, half point
*BING*
Hmm. Okay. I got an answer. This might be tough for you.
Um, what was my biggest disappointment of this past year?
Just last year? Disappointment...
- Mhm...
Tsk- T- There's so many disappointments. Just this year. Just this past year.
You got sick on the tour?... The tour...
Oh.. I guess that would have been a disappointment.
Yeah, but let's focus on like disappointments that were my fault.
'Cuz getting sick wasn't my fault. Let's say that I did something and I.. I disappointed.
Really?!
- Yeah.
I never knew that...
I thought you're always perfect.
In my eyes...
Something about the beginning of this video might disagree with that but I- I just put like: "My Bad Habits".
Like that.
- What do you have bad habit?
Well, it's so hard like this is- like this is basically. It's I...
I'm so ingrained at this point into like a certain habit of like...
making things and like living my life that it's
It's- it's just like super hard to get into good habits when I've got so many bad habits that are in the way.
So like, getting up to exercise in the morning, being consistent about Korean lessons like...
Oooohhh...
- Yeah. That's right.
I forgive you... for that. That wasn't... It's okay... That wasn't specifically.. It's okay- you busy! You busy... Wasn't about you.
- That's okay. That's okay. You're busy, you were exiled.
You exiled yourself. *Mark laughs*
This is a funny question. Do you think.. Do you think I feel too big or too small for my age?
What do you mean too big?
Am I too big or too small...
- Too tall?
for my age?
You could've been a little taller...
( offended-iplier)
You're not quite six-foot. You're under six-foot right?
( b e t r e y a l )
*momiplier laughs*
I'm joking.
No, you're perfect in my eyes.
But that's not the question.
That wasn't the question at all. *giggling*
You just went off on a tangent.
Alright, am I too big or too small for my age? What do you think, I think?
I cannot say that...
That's so personal.
- You abstain...
I'm too big.
- Too big??
( ( w h y ) )
What do you mean too big?
I dunno I guess...
- You're perfect.
Guess I could use it- lose a few pounds.
- Nooooo!!
My ego's too huge and too swole.
No no... You're perfect, honey. Don't change.
I'm- I should've have written that. "I"m perfect."
- No, no! You're too skinny!
Let's do that again hang on. Okay, answer- answer again. Whoa whoa-hoa, am I too big or too small?
TOO SMALL!
I'd-- pffeft.. gheg pfoom perfdt! *offended again*
COME ON! *extreme triggered*
*laughter*
Okay. What chore, do or did I hate the most?
Cleaning your room.
You never pick up anything.
( ouch )
Never?
I would've said... "Dishes".
No wonder I never seen you in the kitchen doing dishes.
*laughter*
Oh uhnn... Okay...
- Okay.
Nice reality check I guess...
What gift from you, have I cherished the most?
Ooooooooooh~
That should be easy...
Your good looks.
*Mark laughs*
That's the best gift I've given to you.
I mean, yeah.
You won the genetic lottery, what they call.
You see? Your mom and dad is just normal average...parents....and I produce this product.
Tsk... tsk... tskk... *but approvingly*
Thats the best gift any mother can give it to any son.
- Wow.
Nice physical.
[Backpat of approval]
I.. I think this in some way is a correct answer cause I put: "unconditional support".
*Mark laughs*
You know I can support all day long but if you look like.. um...
If I'm uggo...
I don't... go... far. *chuckle*
- lf you're ugly! I don't think we can have unconditional support from anybody. *Mark laughs*
...I'm ssseriously...
Harsh realities from Momiplier. (literally crying inside)
So you got "Unconditional Support" from me.... From..
- Mmm.. Mhmmhm.
Blessing of genetic...
Mutation.
I'm freak is what you're saying.
You freak
- Yeah...
I.. I was saying like, you know not at first when I first told you I was dropping out of college things got a little dicey.
but after umm.. after I started- once you realized I started- I could make money from this.
Like you're number one fan the whole way through so that's always good.
It's always- it's always nice to be able to come home and have like food cooked.
Hey, let me tell you as your mother...
Have I ever say no to whatever you are doing? Oh.
(realization hits Momiplier)
...except one time
*Mark's laughter of relief at the face of her honesty*
You were a little upset when you realized I was skipping classes to do YouTube.
Well...I was a little concerned.
- Mmhmm..
But things turned out for the best.
- Mm-hm.
Before I get really angry...
- Okay.
Didn't have time for me to get upset.
Make sense to me.
Okay.
I think that's good enough for there.
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
Ah.. This has been my mom.
She has no social media account so I can't plug her in anyway, but you know.
Thanks, mom for being there for me.
And uh...
even though you only got like three questions right,
I think I'll still give you a passing grade.
- I think I got at least a "B", right?
Uh-huh.. I'll look up some questions for how well I know you and then we can do a video like that.
You don't know me.. it's- thing.
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
If you want to see more stuff like this.
let me know down in the comments below and uh..
Also I'm gonna be going on tour in Australia and
We'll come to back to Amsterdam in July. Australia's in November, Amsterdam in July.
Check out for tickets at tour.markiplier.com or in the link in the description below.
Thanks everybody for watching and as  always, I'll see you in the next video. Buh bye!
-Byee!
*Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan*